[Musique]
michel field pour les journalistes qui
regardaient les manifestations d'hier il
semblait que au delà de la sphère des
sursis et le contenu du service
militaire et peut-être même le principe
du service militaire était en cause
est ce que c'est votre impression est ce
que c'est votre sentiment quelle est
votre position c'est qu'il y ait
d'autres problèmes que celui du sursis
je pense que nous en débattrons tout à
l'heure dans la troisième partie de
l'émission lorsque je voudrais juste
noter deux points importants
d'une part monsieur lui c'est que vous
dites à ces haltes aux excitations halte
aux manifestations dans la rue et c'est
rentrer calmement chez vous nous
réexaminerons le projet mais la seule
chose que je voudrais vous dire monsieur
le ministre c'est que si vous réexaminer
ce projet c'est parce que nous sommes
descendus dans la rue parce que les
lycées sont mis en grève
sinon vous ne l'auriez pas vu donc salue
sa approuve au moins une chose c'est que
nous avons eu un résonne de nouveau
genre à donner je n'ai pas terminé
je voudrais aussi noter le second point
le qui nous sommes le plus important le
mépris avec lesquels vous tenez
aujourd'hui la jeunesse
ainsi des dizaines et des dizaines aux
seconds y est vous le pouvez par vos
déclarations monsieur le ministre
des dizaines et des dizaines de milliers
de jeunes s'organisent dans les lycées
avec un sérieux une discipline que tout
le monde a reconnu parents professeurs
élèves que vous êtes seul à ne pas voir
ont quelquefois même organisé des
contrecoups pour ne pas perdre trop de
temps au niveau de scolaires pour ceux
qui préparer leurs examens qui dans les
manifestations organisée un meilleur
service d'ordre pour éviter toutes les
provocations et tous les incidents et
ses dizaines et ses centaines de
milliers de jeunes qui manifestent
aujourd'hui comment vous analyser la
situation
ce sont des jeux d'été mis dans la rue
par des manipulateurs
quelles sont ces manipulateurs des
manipulateurs gauchistes évidemment d'où
vient-il
comme tous les manipulateurs gauchistes
qui viennent de l'extérieur on sait plus
où l'extérieur steve là ça rappelle une
phrase de goethe danfoss le de danse et
le dehors tout le monde vient toujours
de l'extérieur dans les déclarations
gouvernementales
mais ce n'est pas vrai les lycéens sont
dans les lycées aujourd'hui ils tiennent
des assemblées générales qui
s'organisent en comités de grève
démocratiquement élu il décide des
formes de leur action et ça les
manipulateurs les organisations les
leader que vous saisissiez événements de
mettre sur le devant de la scène tout ça
c'est du vent ça n'existe pas ce sont
les lycéens eux mêmes qui prennent leur
lutte sommes deuxièmes petit point sur
la commune charme et je voudrais
monsieur le ministre
excusez moi d'une part cette commission
armées jeunesse on peut se demander ce
qu'elle représente
quand pour les représentants de la
jeunesse on voit les scouts de france et
qu'on voit les délégués des lycéens aux
luttes se faire repousser par les gardes
mobiles à l'entrée de la commission moi
je me pose des questions sur sa
représentativité
le deuxième grand nettoyage et j'aurais
très vite tu es moche et j'aurais très
vite terminée c'est sur le fait des
succès sur le fait de faire le service
militaire à 18 heures la chose que vous
ne dites pas monsieur fausse d'année
mais vos généraux l'a10 mieux que vous
le rende pas tué le général vanuxem
c'est que beaucoup au gouvernement
beaucoup dans l'armée trouve qu'à 18 ans
je cite vanuxem les esprits sont des
cires plus malléable qu'on peut
facilement
on peut en faire face à des veaux même
quelque chose donc vous avez un bon
camarade ce sont vous officiez qu'il
dise monsieur fontaine et ce n'est pas
un intérieur à dire le mot solution de
votre gouvernement offre qui pensaient
qu'il ya 18 ans on peut faire évidemment
en caserne à l'écart sa liberté
politique sa liberté syndicale dans le
contingent
on peut en faire ce que ce qu'on veut
c'est ça que vous espérez aux métaux les
jeunes très tôt à 18 heures et c'est ça
que nous refusons car et je terminerai
là dessus un slogan qui a été repris ce
qu'a fait l'unité de la jeunesse et pas
seulement les lycéennes qui se battaient
pour des privilèges
vous savez que ce n'est pas ça vous
savez que les jeunes des cités sont en
lutte aujourd'hui avec nous avec les
jeunes oubliés nous ont rejoint hier
c'est qu'ils dénoncent ces manoeuvres
qui tente à une chose c'est embrigader
la jeunesse c'est ce que votre
gouvernement c'est ce que la jeunesse
aujourd'hui refusent un simple petit mot
sur les manipulations dans n'ouvre le
nouvel observateur de cette semaine vous
êtes interviewé et vous dit ceci le
mouvement des manipulés par personne
notre ambition n'est pas de tout
contrôler mais d'apprendre d'apprendre
aux dizaines de milliers de lycéens qui
sont en grève depuis deux semaines ce
qu'est l'organisation démocratique dame
et lui tout seul subissent une bonne
manière de moi n'est pas ce que vous
dites vous expliquer l'axé vous qu il
leur apprenait et vous dites ensuite il
est vrai maintenant que nous avons joué
un rôle important dans la mobilisation
actuelle en organisant dès la mi février
les premiers comités contre la loi debré
alors voyez vous
relisez maison je vous contredisez même
proscrit tout seul vous le savez et nous
n'y sommes presque plus pour rien
maintenant nous sommes partie prenante
c'est tout et nous nous en félicitons
est ce que peut être une seconde tête
[Musique]